lewis was elected as a fellow of the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences in
2008 earned the outstanding achievement
award from the University of Minnesota
and The Herald or Johnson diversity
service award from the University of
Michigan and as current earned several
honorary Doctorate degrees a native of
Tidewater Virginia hello to all the one
residents of Tidewater Virginia Lewis
earned his undergraduate degree in
history and psychology from Concordia
College in more hurt Moorhead Minnesota
and his PhD in history from the
University of Minnesota just in case you
are wondering in a few minutes you will
realize that dr. Lewis's Minnesota
accent is somewhat very different from
my Iowa accent a neighboring state dr.
Lewis
there's actually very nice to travel the
world and realize that other people have
actually made their way from the Norfolk
Portsmouth Tidewater area to other parts
of the country as well so salut super
thank you for that introduction I was
reminded that yesterday would have been
my mother's birthday she passed away a
few years ago she would have loved that
introduction I have to have to say good
morning to you all and I think it is
still good morning good morning thank
you we gathered this Sunday morning to
salute you the carnegie mellon
university class of 2016 for staying the
course overcoming challenges setting
aside failures appropriately accepting
success and graduating this is an
awesome achievement and i'm honored to
share in a moment in fact i would like
to thanks to michelle rogers president
of CMU and provost farnham jahani and as
well as the carnegie mellon university
board of trustees for this wonderful
opportunity to receive an honorary
degree from this spectacular institution
my personal relationship with Carnegie
Mellon began over three decades ago when
my good friend Joe Trotter dr. Joe
Trotter invited me to speak about my
research on African American migrants
inevitably that opportunity yielded the
privilege of serving on CMU humanities
and Social Sciences College review panel
chairing an external review committee
for the history department and having
the chance to assist dr. Trotter and
funding and launching cause the Center
for African American urban studies and
the economy which is just recently
celebrated its 20th anniversary yes
that's great
now I'm both humbled and delighted to
speak on behalf of this year's very
diverse and distinguished class of
honorary degree recipients a group that
includes as you've heard an acclaimed
stage and screen star who counts among
her accomplishments and Academy Award at
Golden Globe and two Emmys a television
icon and Emmy award-winning writer and
actress who has influenced the lives of
millions of children a prolific
innovator with over 1,100 patents
worldwide and one of the most successful
venture capitalists in the world
graduates make a note to yourself learn
more about these folks it is also an
honor to be standing here before a group
of students that has been vetted by the
vigorous academic standards and
requirements of one of the world's
finest universities you have been given
the carnegie mellon stamp of approval
and with it comes a certain level of
attainment and responsibility that many
years ago if you've heard i walked
across a similar stage at a small
liberal arts college in minnesota to
accept my diploma like many of you I was
able to join the ranks of the newly
educated because someone believed in me
in my case it was started with my
maternal grandmother while her dream was
deferred she strategized to ensure that
my dream would not be denied it was the
early 20th century and my grandmother
has saved money twice to attend st.
Augustine College in Raleigh North
Carolina each time she did her father
asked her for the money to save an older
brother from losing his home if that
truth is he lost at home during the
Great Depression a domestic in the
segregated south for most of her working
days my grandmother preserved her dream
of being educated by passing it alone
when it came time for my for her
daughter my mother to graduate from high
school my grandmother Center first to
the Norfolk division
a Virginia State today's norfolk state
university but my grandmother feared the
demands of living at home would distract
my mother from her studies so there's
god-fearing church-going woman played
the daily number of what was referred to
back then as a poor person lottery as
she won even though my grandmother could
have used that money to ease the burdens
of her own life she stopped she chose
instead to send my mother to st.
Augustine college because she believed
just that fervently in the
transformative power of Education when I
came along the only question I was
allowed to entertain was which college
will you attend so I stand before you
today because of my grandmother's
determination to pay a dream forward my
mother and I inherited the belief that
the educated have a responsibility to
pay back the faith invested in them by
working to in some way improve the world
let's see let's see a show of hands how
many of you have family friends and
teachers who backed and support you
through your higher education experience
thank you please join me in recognizing
these special individuals where they
rock is round of applause
their job is done in fact if you listen
closely you'll hear some sighs of relief
coming from parents in the audience now
your job like mine when I graduated is
to never confuse the attainment of an
education with what it means to be
educated graduation marks a moment in
time when you have a symbol the
necessary credits to earn a degree but
being educated be an educator requires
you to deploy the discipline of mind
that comes with a pursuit of knowledge
for the betterment not only of yourself
and your family but also the greatest
society I graduated an opposed Vietnam
era of gas lines student protests and
racial desegregation I knew what had
been and what was happening at the time
but I had no idea what to expect in the
years and decades to come for example in
1978 it was nearly impossible to
conceive of desktop computers much less
a world so completely integrated with
powerful personal computing ability that
resides on the phone this think about
man it hasn't been that long ago back
then when I imagine the future I
pictured a world akin to the Jetsons
there are people in its audio old enough
to remember the Justin's a prime-time
animated series that predated the
symptoms by almost 30 years his world
was populated with space-age families
sassy robots and flying cars computers
delivered both instant meals and
instantaneous medical diagnosis and
cures for diseases worth just one
individually formulated pill away flash
forward to today and flying cars are
still a matter of fantasy but we aren't
that far away from a semi-autonomous
autumn
bill gene mapping is almost commonplace
in the development of customized
treatment plans robotics is now offered
as part of the curriculum in many high
schools across the United States and
artificial intelligent protocols such as
IBM Watson regularly beat humans at
games of knowledge and logic it is said
that at CMU you do not imagine the
future you created but in judge indulge
me for a few seconds look ahead
graduates look ahead to 25 years from
now what do you see marriage children
sadly maybe divorce and success it's
true but what about on the technology
front will it be that the discipline of
robotics is ushered in a new age of
productivity and profitability a world
where artificial intelligence alters the
makeup of a work as well as a
composition of a workforce today a
single retailer can employ nearly
100,000 people around the nation to move
products from regional sites to consumer
homes there is however speculation that
robots could replace these workers in
short order not next year but tomorrow
what happens then do we simply shrug and
acknowledge that progress always comes
at a price or do we examine the broader
social and economic implications
graduates many of you will certainly be
the architects of the next technological
revolution but while you are developing
devices and programs that enhance
efficiency and perhaps even save lives
you must also simultaneously challenge
yourselves to solve for the impact of
these advancements as our economy shifts
away from human based work from a
human-based workforce to machine driven
labor will you make accommodations for
newly technologically disenfranchised
undoubtedly CMU has prepared you to meet
the exponentially increasing
technological demands of a growing
global economy in a more environmentally
conscious manner but what additional
tools and insights might you need to be
both successful contributors and
successful global citizens 25 years from
now with the courses that you took in
history philosophy and literature your
experimentation with theater and the
arts or your interdisciplinary courses
and studies and study abroad prove just
as useful as the work that made you a
student of science math and engineering
or not for those of you in the arts and
humanities with a value of your degree
decrease in a technology-focused world
or increase because people with your
background and training are suddenly in
short supply it is critical that all of
you envision yourselves as part of the
creative society which produces creative
solutions so historically we have looked
to those coming out of the Arts and
Humanities to help us transform what we
know and how we know it today
engineering math and computer science
have truly evolved into creative
disciplines more people worldwide a
familiar familiar with Siri that any
book play on SI reading written in the
last 100 years the engineers and
technologists at Apple have created
something that it's infiltrated our
consciousness like few other works of
art ever have and that's actually
important to think about and dwell on
and think through the implications yes
science engineering and math alone are
not enough case and point 911 despite
the utilization of very sophisticated
machinery and highly skilled technicians
we failed to intercept the terrorists
because 911 have more
do with religion and ideology then with
probes drones and surveillance devices
similarly engineers successfully build a
well in a West African village not too
long ago to ensure a ready supply of
clean water you failed to take into
consideration broader cultural
implications to their surprise the women
who haul the water continue to walk all
the way to the river despite the risk
when questioned by anthropologists the
women is playing that no one had asked
them where to build a well you see the
hauling of the water had a social
function as well as a utilitarian one
the women used a time to socialize and
get away from their children and the men
folk both of these examples serve as a
powerful reminder that studying a
multiplicity of perspectives has real
worth when we're trying to solve real
problems human interaction as we all
well no it's messy it's not always
scientifically based or mathematically
predictable nor is it linear sometimes
you simply cannot get from point A to
point B in a straight line this is
suggests that the world is complex any
issues that we face are indeed complex
and it requires that technologists
consult with social scientists that
human is work with engineers and the
scientists and artists collaborate to
solve problems and try new possibilities
graduates as we move forward in life and
as you move forward in life you must
strive to be in conversations across
lines of difference exchanging insights
and ideas in a profound and noble way
with people of different racial academic
and social economic backgrounds luckily
today's technologies eclipse eclipse
time and distance making it possible for
you to connect in real time with people
in different geographic zones across the
United States and around the world
you will also need to recognize the
importance of being embedded in
community and actively working to
improve the american form of democracy
that's not just about voting it's about
the ways in which we think about the
opportunity for all and actually being
able to gather information across a
broad spectrum of media that will allow
you to fashion your understanding of a
world or to put it bluntly to be able to
tell the difference between garbage and
the real stuff now if this election
cycle is a harbinger of things to come
successfully stored in the garbage from
the real stuff will become the hallmark
of an enlightened citizen yeah we can
think about that for a second and this
would be true whether you are in Berlin
Beijing or Birmingham you must remember
to ask why to research independently to
pursue truth and to affirm your
commitment to honesty integrity and the
common good now look to the future once
more to your 25th reunion this time what
do you see more changes in the
technological landscape greater
diversity how about improved
connectedness hopefully you see your
future selves as in a strictly linked to
the america america and the world both
the opportunities and the challenges
because you haven't shrunk from either
keep looking are you a key player in the
creation of a new and technologically
responsible golden age are you balancing
your desire to create bigger better
faster with the need to sustain a
healthy and vibrant economy in which all
members have a stake more specifically
on you the leader that Carnegie Mellon
has prepared you to become
or are you merely participating in the
creation of cool new stuff I challenge
it I challenge you because you're the
best and the brightest as you've heard
and you will hear no doubt many more
times over the course of this day in the
next few days so graduates of 2016 stand
up
and I would ask that you repeat after me
we the 2016 graduating class of Carnegie
Mellon
well do the
we will discover the unscareable we will
change the world responsibly let's try
that one more time we will change the
world responsibly and then one more time
we will change the world responsibly
thank you you may sit down if you remain
faithful to this moment in time you will
have done far more than earn a degree
you will have use your skills talents
and intellect for the benefit of all I
am confident that you understand the
significance and I am grateful to have
had this opportunity to see you off on
your journey I'm truly excited for you
I'm excited for the world and I extend
my sincerest congratulations to well
graduates and do good because you can
thank
you